Programming your BMW Z4 key fob syncs it
with your car's immobilizer and body
control module, enabling functions like
lock, unlock, panic alarm, and engine
start. For standard remote pairing on
older models like 2009 2016, use the
physical method. Insert key and
ignition, cycle to position one, press
unlock button three times within 10
seconds. Comfort access adds keyless
entry and start. For newer models, pair
via iDrive, start engine with key, hold
fob to steering wheel, follow oncreen
prompts. Recent updates include OTAA via
BMW connected drive app for remote
programming on 2009 plus models. Digital
Key Plus uses NFC enabled phones,
reducing physical fob reliance.
Procedures vary by model year and trim,
so consult your owner's manual.
Incorrect programming can disable your
vehicle, so accuracy is critical. For
standard remotes on older BMW Z4 models,
follow these steps to pair your key fob.
For comfort access on G29 BMW Z4 models,
use these steps to pair your key fob.
If you encounter pairing issues, start
by replacing the key fob battery.
Interference from nearby electronics can
cause problems, so try pairing in a
different location. For advanced
diagnostics, use an OBD2 scanner or
BMW's ISTA software. Remember, enhanced
security features after 2023 require
following procedures exactly for your
model year. If issues continue, consult
your local BMW dealer.